Hello YouTube friends I'm Diego bald And
these are my 10 essential objects
[Music]
Well my first essential object
is cards I love to play games all
the time I'm a very playful person and
for me the best game that exists is
Magic the gadening  Definitely and the
second one and the one I like since I was
little
is Pokémon
Well, look, it's not so much that there is
a difficult card to find but rather
about making the best deck.
shooting a
movie I'm always playing Solo
against myself it's a bit ridiculous but
it's what keeps me focused
with Magic it's different because Magic is the
most complicated game there is for me
and it's like a game that yes I try and
try to be like  ready for tournaments
So if I buy a lot of Magic that I
try to be up to date all the time
because it's also a business
then I won't be able to use this card
in three months  Those are prohibited and the
other thing that I really like is
Poker and my favorite game is called Speed
and Widow because sometimes people
ask me if I also do
magic tricks but not all I do is
bet and take away his  money
[Music]
Well, my next object is sunglasses.
The truth is, I'm really blind, I haven't
prepared my eyes and well, I never wore
sunglasses until about two years ago and
now I definitely can't go out without
them, it's like a kind of addiction
I have all colors I'm not proud of
I have my favorites like
weekly and apart from that I lose them, I mean,
the glasses don't last more than a month
so I have to
constantly buy spare parts I've sat
on them a thousand times too and I break them,
everything happens to me but when  I find some
that I like very much,
rather I stop using them, I keep them for
very special moments, my first
glasses are stolen, my dad was very
cool, I had them with me for about a year
Until I lost them, it was a music festival.
I wore them at night, a bad idea
and I lost them. Well, what
you steal, they steal from you.
Well, I have a gang and I live in
Mexico. I have a hard time
finding tennis shoes and every time I  I buy
tennis shoes Or I find tennis shoes with my number that I
always try to find if they are Adidas
because I love them I take great care of them and I
preserve them a lot and A curiosity is that
when I find I buy three of the same
pair because I don't know when I will
find my number again as I walk
I don't have a car all day I like to
move around walking Well, I need you to have them
that are very comfortable and above all
that I can wear them with anything
I don't like to think much about what I
wear the white outputs are like my my
fascination these have less  After a
week they have about five weeks of
days left, you have them with the ones I did
high school with, they are not good, they are not
sneakers, they are the brown shoes, they speak, that is,
they are already broken, here it is  n ripped
everywhere But that and some pants
that were like my second skin for
years I keep them to see if one day I paint them or to
see what I do But I do have them
Well, I haven't been painting for a long
time but
I was in Barcelona during the year
past and it gave me Coby And I had to
stay locked in a room
for about 15 days and they took
some pencils and markers and now I'm addicted
to painting all the time and it's something that helps me a
lot to concentrate If someone
is telling me something O  I'm
learning a script or
I just have to hang out drawing
helps a lot like channeling everything where it's
just become more than a hobby like
a necessity
[Music]
Well I don't have a
very clear technique so once like well
Playing I learned to break the markers
because I usually break them because I
can squeeze them for example or suddenly
I can play to make shapes with them
but I don't necessarily draw things as
I will explain to you  like shapes or very specific things,
the truth is that everything is more
abstract for me.
The only problem is that when
I'm working, the
make-up department hates me.
I did this a while ago.
They're kind of abstract, but
what they allow me is not to pay
much attention to what I'm
drawing either. And then with color
you can do more funnier
things, crazier things can come out.
I don't know about abstract painting like the little boy
in this one.  About 300 paintings a year ago and it's
the first time he sent them to be framed.
I have about 25 left because every time
there is a party at my house I give them to
everyone. I like to play a lot
with shapes and as I tell them to draw, it
has  a lot to do with
channeling my attention and then it has
become something like I can't
stop, kind of addictive but well, I imagine it
's a good addiction.
Well, my dad's family is d  e
Oaxaca I have a close relationship with
Oaxaca, it is a state that I love and well,
I learned to drink Mezcal with my
grandfather, may he rest in peace. I never saw
my grandfather drunk, but he did drink a
little mezcal after each
meal and well, I always  He told something
that I really like to think about and that is that
mezcal is the true essence of
Oaxaca and it is like the strongest heritage
that Mexicans have is with the
spirit of the agave, so
for me mezcal is not just my country, yes.
not my grandfather and it's my favorite life
so if it's a good mezcal it has to make
these little
bubbles we call it the ring but to
market it for example here in the
United States they have to filter it
so if you realize the mezcal is
clean it only generates these like little
bubbles  because of the oxygen but I really
like it and the mezcal that my
grandfather made is a mezcal that he cured.
So, believe it or not,
we Mexicans put chicken breasts
inside mezcal for  many
months or cinnamon or cloves to give it a
flavor and when my grandfather died
we drank a mezcal that was over 45
years old and was curing, which is what
we say when we prepare it and well
for me that is a delicacy almost an elixir
[  Music]
Well, my relationship with the Apple
watch has to do with the fact that I am very
distracted no no I don't usually check the
messages my mother tells me, for example,
that she goes crazy when she sees that I have 3000 of
these emails in gmail that I have not read and
that she tells him  it gives anxiety Well, for
me the Apple watch It is a
necessary tool to be able to
be in contact with my work all the time
and to be able to communicate
with my family and my friends and that I do
not forget things so
basically it is like a  babysitter
I never remember my mother without a
book in her hands my mother is a publicist
and she is my best friend so you think
surrounded by books all the time and
when I was 13 years old I wanted to be a poet
until  I realized that if you want to be a
poet you will never be a poet and I can't
read novels anymore I don't have as much
attention as it takes to read novels
so from the last seven eight years
to here I dedicate myself to reading Well yes
there is something that  I like to do it a lot, it's
like just
grabbing small phrases and well, a
bit as if Ching were there. I like to
start the day reading a little poem
and realizing apart that if I read it again
the next day it's different right
now you can't talk much  of him
but her husband Ted Hughes
who was not such a good guy
he has a poem that I
liked very much when I was little and he treated it on my
legs called God dog even if you don't
believe it I have tattooed God dog on my legs
Well  I grew up listening more like
the underground velveto layer Tomb Ways to
those types of situations
and nothing can make me feel worse than people
who say they don't like reggaeton.
For me, this is the greatest artist
that exists right now.  For a long time and I
usually wake up every day
before exercising Listening to songs
by Benito from Bad Bunny and
well, nothing also fills me with Pride and it's a bit of a
shock that the biggest and most important artist on
the planet today is a
Latino Puerto Rican I think
they are inviting us  to the party and
we're not going out anymore
[Music]
these are the pants I wear I almost
always like to paint and I wear them for
two reasons first they are very comfortable and
second they have this
where I can get things stuck and I love it
it's called workers this  type of pants
are dikis I started using them When
I started to stain my wardrobe from the
movies at work or to
stain my hands and then stain all my clothes
it took me a while to understand but you
need to have clothes to paint otherwise
absolutely everything is going to have stains
of  colors and I like to have
the painting studio the furthest from
my room so that my studio chaos
doesn't come together like my room So
e  Well, yes, I imagine that it changes something in
the mindset. Above all, I like to use the
jumps and stand up straight when I paint and
feel there a little more bloody
[Music]
Well, I don't wear jewelry, I don't wear
rings, I've
never used them as a chain and
how can they  see, it's very old and this
chain was given to me by my girlfriend
and well now it has become a
kind of amulet I think it's nice how to
give certain importance to objects
Although they don't really have it, they don't.
So when I do castings for
example I like to bring it in  the bag and
when I have an important or complicated day,
I like to carry it in my
backpack or bring it with me, for me it is
like an object that gives me affection
and sometimes I also wear it but I
use it more as a talisman.
I really like comfortable clothes and I am  I am a
fan of sweatshirts and
hoodies and walk very loosely This is
my favorite sweatshirt, it
is the one I try to wear the most and the
truth is that I already bought two because
I stained one just because  Before, I had a
white of the same brand and I stained it.
So now I try to take care of this one to see
if the coffee lasts, it
is drunk hot, it is drunk without
milk and it is drunk without sugar.
Every day in the morning I have
a coffee and I really like the espresso it reminds me a
lot of how my dad is a
coffee grower but not a Colorado bone and well,
for example, we really like to
collect different coffee makers to make
different types of coffee and it's a
conversation that we constantly have,
not like what are you drinking right now or how do
you like to drink it right now, but well, it's
something like the books that have always
been like me, so then I smell
coffee and I feel at home in a
way
[Applause] Well,
these were my  10
essential items and see you very soon
[Music]